[Music]
hi and welcome we're here at the
security zone and next with Lorena
Crowley from the Google cloud security
team hi Lorena hey you think Lorena
you're an expert on ransomware attacks
which are a common problem for companies
can you tell us more about it
you're right you think ransomware
attacks are a common problem for
companies far and wide a recent report
on malware attacks showed that a company
is hit by a ransomware attack every 40
seconds and we're helping protect
employees and companies from these
attacks so if I'm a security admin I'm
trying to protect my company from
ransomware attacks how should I approach
it the first thing you need to do is
understand the way ransom attackers work
one of the most common attack vectors
for ransomware is email as you can see
the attacker sends phishing emails but
malicious malware attached they're
trying to trick employees and opening up
these emails a second common attack
vector is website attacks attackers
embed malicious malware into web sites
that look legitimate and employees may
be tricked into downloading the
malicious malware thinking of something
else Wow
so whenever employees or opening up
emails are browsing the web it could be
at risk of accidentally downloading
malware unfortunately yes and there's
even other sophisticated ransomware
attack vectors when it's hackers try to
create new malware variants these new
malware variants are designed to sneak
by existing detectors and perimeter
defenses that operating systems have so
as a security admin trying to protect
against these attacks the first thing
you really need to do is understand
these vectors and then you need to
understand the business impacts that
successful ransomware attacks can have
let's take a look over here at a company
that has a lot of ransomware
vulnerabilities we're looking at a
company here that has a lot of legacy
systems that haven't been updated in a
while because of that there are several
key vulnerabilities that ransomware
attackers could exploit the first
vulnerability this company has is a
legacy on premise email server these
servers are the gatekeepers for letting
emails into users inboxes when
ransomware attackers send malicious
emails into the server if the malware
detection in the email server hasn't
been updated in a while it's gonna be
easier for these emails to get through
to users inboxes so what happens when a
user SE opens one of these malware files
well when an employee opens ups one of
these files their device is encrypted
and they receive a message on their
screen demanding a cryptocurrency
payment before the device is unencrypted
the employee can access any of their
apps or data which makes them
unproductive and the company may have to
pay ransom to get the device and
encrypted but that's not it
another vulnerability this company has
is that they're using an out-of-date
legacy browser when ransomware attackers
embed malware into websites these
out-of-date browsers aren't necessarily
able to detect them so that means you
can just have more employees getting
tricked into downloading these files on
websites that's right the impact of an
out-of-date browser could mean more
successful web-based malware attacks in
your organization if a company
experiences a lot of these different
attacks across their different
departments the costs and losses in
productivity really start to add up one
last runner ability this company has is
that it's running a traditional
operating system that hasn't been
updated with the latest patches that
means this OS may let employees run an
executable file that is risky so if an
employee accidentally downloads malware
file this operating system isn't going
to do anything to stop it
ransomware attackers exploit both known
and unknown vulnerabilities in these
operating systems to lock user systems
down
Wow so this legacy company isn't doing
so well no right now this company is
struggling they're suffering with lower
productivity and they even have ransom
payments to deal with yeah these
ransomware attacks seem to be really
able to slow down the whole business he
really can and so as a security admin
how can I help protect employees and the
business from these sorts of attacks
well I'm glad you asked that why don't
we go take a look at another company
that is prepared to take these
ransomware attacks on
this company is using Google clouds help
protect employees and their business
from the impact of ransomware attacks
they have multiple layers of protection
first thing this company is using to
protect employees is Gmail Gmail is a
cloud-based email service that protects
employees by blocking ransomware emails
before they hit their inbox Gmail can
automatically detect even sophisticated
ransomware attacks by identifying them
within emails and blocking them before
they hit a user's inbox so ransomware
attacks can be detected and blocked why
don't we take a look at the second
protection this company has in place
Chrome browser
the Safe Browsing technology in a Chrome
browser alerts users who may be trying
to visit a risky site
as a security admin you can add
additional controls for example if
you're leveraging auto-updates
employees will have the most up-to-date
protection available even against new
malware variants and with additional
protections like sandboxing and site
isolation if a user does is it a risky
site that malware won't spread between
tabs or processes that's great so if an
employee browses to one of these sites
they're gonna get alerted right and
they're gonna be safe
the last protection we'll look at is how
this company is using Chrome OS to
protect from ransomware attacks Chrome
OS is a cloud-based operating system
because it runs in the cloud it prevents
employees from running executable files
unlike traditional operating systems so
even if an employee downloads a
malicious malware file the operating
system blocks it from executing Chrome
OS offers additional safeguards things
like auto updates that help keep
employees completely protected so as a
security admin these tools will help
businesses avoid all kinds of these
attacks exactly between Gmail Chrome
browser and chrome OS they're all
working together to help provide
employees and businesses the security
they need to stay productive and to
prevent them from paying money to
ransomware attackers that is so great
thanks so much Alena for explaining how
Google Cloud is protecting companies
from ransomware attacks all over the
world thanks for having me you think
[Music]